Eddie j'ai soif ne t'inquiète pas le
champagne tu veux des choses que tu dois
payer pour eux où je suis PR qui représentes-tu
clairement je jolie petite épice Emma girl
power et la reine Noor chérie tu ne le
sais pas mais Kate Moss est  changer son
PR nous devons faire démarrer le bar Kate par
Marilyn tapis rouge au plus grand
événement de mode de Londres de l'année
oh oh oh mon dieu tu vois Carrie Carrie
je vais rouler la main salut Johnny
tu ne te souviens pas de moi oh  mon dieu je ne peux pas
croire que tu es si vivant la police continue
de chercher les termes de comment cela peut-il être je
veux dire tu sais que tu as tué Kate
Moss nous devons partir nous devons nous tromper
amener où le sud de la France
tout le monde est un criminel  chance le domaine
d'un yacht qu'est-ce que c'est une sorte de
soirée lesbienne tardive où sont les hommes
qu'ils ne Britanniques l'emportent cela pourrait
être notre vie à venir Je ne reviens pas en
ta faveur prêt
[Musique]
toi